c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir ce rebondissement
judiciaire en république démocratique du
congo la cour de cassation a annulé la
condamnation à 13 ans de prison de vital
kamerhe la sphère qui visent l'ancien
directeur de cabinet du président félix
tshisekedi a été envoyé et sera de
nouveau jugé nous serons à kinshasa dans
ce journal ces manifestations contre le
président tunisien des milliers de
personnes se sont rassemblées dans le
centre de tunis dimanche pour protester
contre la dissolution du parlement par
cai cède les détails dans ce journal à
la fin de cette édition nous irons en
libye est la découverte d'un métier très
sollicité en ce moment ce mois de
ramadhan les restaurateurs de coran
leurs ateliers sont pris d'assaut par
des clients qui souhaitent restaurer un
coran hérité d'un grand père
on commence donc par ce nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère vital
kamerhe en république démocratique du
congo la cour de cassation a annulé ce
lundi l'arrêt de la cour d'appel qui
avait condamné en juin dernier l'ancien
directeur de cabinet du président félix
tshisekedi à 13 ans de prison la faire
sera de nouveau jugé la correspondance à
kinshasa de clément bonin
pour motiver sa décision la cour de
cassation a évoqué une violation du
droit de la défense elle estime que la
cour d'appel aurait dû citer le prévenu
c'est à dire le convoquer formellement
alors qu'il n'a reçu en réalité qu'une
simple notification de la date
d'audience l'afer a donc été renvoyée
devant la cour d'appel qui sera composée
de nouveaux juges pour rejugé la faire
sur le fond dans un communiqué les
soutiens de vital kamerhe salue ce lundi
une victoire de la justice et espère
désormais un acquittement pour rappel
l'ancien directeur de cabinet du
président félix tshisekedi est poursuivi
pour le détournement de fonds publics
dans le cadre du programme présidentiel
dit des 100 jours il s'agit de fonds
destinés notamment à la construction de
logements pour les militaires et les
policiers vital kamerhe avait été
condamné en première instance à 20 ans
de prison une peine qui avait ensuite
été réduite en appel à treize ans de
réclusion en juin dernier et en décembre
vital kamerhe avait bénéficié d'une
remise en liberté provisoire pour
raisons de santé et se trouve d'ailleurs
toujours en france où il reçoit des
soins médicaux
l'ancien ministre nigérien de
l'intérieur ousmane cissé a été écroué
vendredi après avoir été accusé d'être
impliqué dans deux tentatives de coup
d'état présumé en 2021 et 2022 les
détails avec harold carr d'après
plusieurs sources militaires l'ex
ambassadeur pourrait rester dans la
prison de beer nine gars auraient dit si
la tenue de son procès il rejoindra en
détention le lieutenant abdramane mots
mais aussi le capitaine gourouza tous
deux accusés d'avoir pris le
commandement le 31 mars 2021 d'un
bataillon de soldats qui se sont
attaqués au palais présidentiel c'est
donc à la justice militaire le tribunal
militaire qui statuera sur l'avenir des
trois accusés en attendant l'enquète
continue cissé ousmane ibrahim ancien
ministre de l'intérieur de 2010 à 2011
ne s'est pour l'instant pas exprimé
publiquement son avocat n'ont plus cette
arrestation elle intervient quelques
jours après à peine après la date
anniversaire de l'investiture de
l'actuel président nigérien mohamed
bazoum à ce jour plusieurs militaires
qui pourrait être impliquée dans cette
tentative de coup d'état l'année
dernière sont encore recherchées
en tunisie plus d'un millier de
manifestants se sont rassemblés au
centre de tunis pour protester contre le
président kaïs aide qui a récemment
dissous le parlement une majorité de ces
manifestants étaient des partisans du
parti islamiste and are tableau rambert
stecher
en plein coeur de la capitale des
milliers de tunisiens se sont à nouveau
mobilisés ce dimanche pour dénoncer les
dérives autoritaires de leur président
kaïs aide s'est trahi lui même il a
trahi le peuple et la constitution qu'il
avait promis de respecter
le 31 mars dernier kaïs sayyed avait
annoncé la dissolution du parlement
tunisien déjà suspendu depuis juillet et
quelques jours plus tard plusieurs
membres de l'opposition dont le chef du
parti islamiste ennahda était entendu
par la justice sur leur rôle présumé
dans un complot contre l'état mais pour
ses adversaires ce sont les attaques
répétées de kaïs sayed contre les
institutions parlementaires qui met en
péril la démocratie tunisienne
nombre de tunisiens lui reproche
également son incapacité à sortir le
pays d'une crise économique de plus en
plus sévères
et
qui pèse lourd sur l'économie tunisienne
sur les finances /
le quotidien des tunisiens
vivats de plus en plus mal samedi le
chef de l'état avait affirmé que des
élections législatives prévues en
décembre permettrait la formation d'un
nouveau parlement reflétant la volonté
du peuple mais ces annonces n'ont pas
convaincu l'opposition qui demande un
scrutin dans les trois mois à venir
comme le prévoit la constitution
tunisienne
dans las de l'actualité en bref et en
images cette annonce de l'union
européenne ce lundi l'ue a décidé
d'arrêter ses missions de formation et
d'entraînement de l'armée malienne et de
la garde nationale le chef de la
diplomatie européenne a toutefois
précisé que lui rester présentes au
sahel et se déploiera dans les pays
voisins
la question du sahara occidental
les indépendantistes du front polisario
vont annoncer dimanche rond pour tout
contact avec le gouvernement espagnol de
pedro sanchez après un revirement de
madrid le 18 mars dernier en faveur de
la position marocaine jusqu'ici
l'espagne affiché sa neutralité
cet accord entre l'italie et l'algérie
le premier ministre italien mario draghi
était à alger pour tenter de réduire la
dépendance énergétique de son pays à la
russie un accord a été signé avec
l'algérie pour l'augmentation de ses
exportations de gaz vers la péninsule
l'algérie et le deuxième fournisseur en
gaz de l'italie dernière la russie
en république démocratique du congo les
différents conflits ont fait depuis des
années de nombreuses victimes civiles
mais pas que les animaux ont aussi payé
un lourd tribut je vous emmène à louis
rault ou le centre de réhabilitation des
primates accueille une centaine de
chimpanzés blessé par la guerre ou
capturé par des braconniers
nous sommes dans le parc national de
kahuzi biega dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo six cent mille
hectares de jungle située entre deux
volcans éteints parmi la faune qui
habitent de nombreuses espèces de
primates
dans cette région du pays l'insécurité
les conflits le braconnage ont laissé
des traces sur les singes des centaines
d'entre eux ont été capturés et
maltraiter les rescapés se retrouve
désormais ici dans le centre de
réhabilitation des primates louis rault
des vétérinaires s'occupe de soigner les
chimpanzés gorilles et bonobo arracher
des griffes du braconnier on essaie de
mettre tous les moyens en place pour
commenter ce que d'abord on peut sauver
la vie de l'animal s'il s'agit de cas
des blessures et
la grande soirée on peut voir d'abord
premiers mots comment arrêter
l'hémorragie et puis annexé tel animal
de 6-2 puis la mennais d'art sacré
toujours les primates consomment chacun
six kilos de nourriture par jour et les
bébés sont nourris au biberon pour
certains le séjour ici est bénéfique
mais pour d'autres les peler blessures
sont trop importante pour permettre une
guérison complète
les vétérinaires du centre font
également état d'un manque de moyens et
à part l'implication des coupelles marc
désert a sans trop ça dans la peau d'un
chef des cinq sont des efforts des
personnes de bonne volonté qui essaient
déjà comment protéger nos animaux qui
sont
plus d'une centaine de singe habite dans
le centre de louis rault dans l'espoir
d'un jour pouvoir les relâcher dans leur
habitat naturel
pour finir je vous emmène en libye
découvrir un métier qui ne manque pas
d'activités en ce moment celui de
restaurateurs de coran pendant le mois
de ramadan leur travail est intense de
nombreux clients affluent dans leurs
ateliers pour solliciter leur
savoir-faire pour afin de conserver les
ouvrages souvent hérité de leur grand
père wassim cornette
dans cet atelier de tripoli c'est
l'affluence des grands jours ici des
ouvriers s'attellent à la restauration
d'anciens exemplaires du coran en libye
la tradition et d'acheter un coran avant
le début du mois du ramadan mais
certains préfèrent conserver de vieux
exemplaires souvent hérité de personnes
qui leur sont chers
le processus est minutieux les ouvrages
les plus endommagés nécessite plusieurs
heures d'un travail d'orfèvre ils
doivent être défait restaurer puits
reliés à nouveau la main d'oeuvre est
gratuite l'atelier ne fait payer que les
quelques euros du matériel utilisé
l'engouement est tel que le magasin
organise de nombreux ateliers
depuis 2008 plus de mille cinq cents
stagiaires s'y sont formés
en plus d'être un acte de générosité
c'est pour lui également un travail de
mémoire en 14 ans près d'un demi million
d'exemplaires du coran ont été restaurés
ici
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition se lie à
kara sénat et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis
[Musique]